so people watching live we appreciate
all of you for hanging out with us here
and we rolling deep man we're already at
24 people lives we appreciate y'all for
hanging out here
yeah and um
I think there's two things as we get to
people's questions I would love to hear
about your experience World Series that
uh we were we were both at and um I'd
love to share my experience with kind of
like the first hot breath event
um that went down this past weekend
courtesy of the hot breath verse that uh
was very inspiring very moving and
emotional and
um just a great a great sign of what's
to come here with this community there's
a lot of cool things popping and it's
all thanks to the peeps watching live or
listening later so um
it's a beautiful thing
I guess I'll start with that since I was
carrying on the momentum into it I
realized as I stopped I was like I guess
I'll just talk about this yeah but I
mean you did say you were gonna start
with it so you might as well continue
with it
sorry I'm just staring at my hair in the
camera just like is this is this what
we're doing and the zit in my forehead
just that's just that's just God right
there like oh you want to look good well
there you go there's a zit right in your
eyebrow
to keep you humble
um it's like oh you want to get gussied
up well don't forget that you were born
in a trailer in Rome Georgia and don't
you forget it
no matter how rich and famous you get
Don't You Forget from the mud fam but
the roots from the mud
so
two hot breathers hot breath or OG's
Bobby Sutton and Joyce Lyles put
together an event
here in Villa Rica Georgia
and it was all hot breathers were on the
show and they put the show together
because they were inspired by kind of
the spirit of hot breath and how we
always talk about Comics helping comics
and also Comics not waiting on an
opportunity but creating it themselves
so these are two comedians that were
like well let's put that into practice
and they put together an amazing show
at hickstown brewing in Villa Rica
Georgia they traveled all from Alabama
to make it happen
it was an incredible show everyone
killed it everyone in the audience had a
great time
and it really was
kind of the first
physical
representation I think of what we have
been working on throughout the pandemic
where it was comics online trying to
figure it out and help each other
through this crazy time
so now actually to I had met Bobby once
pre-pandemic but it might as well like
the pandemic you know so much changed so
it was like meeting her again for the
first time and then Joyce for the first
time
and it was really cool to see what we're
building online here actually
in person meeting these people and then
seeing it actually like working like it
was a really
Dope Show it was a lot of fun it was a
great success great success so I'm I
just love seeing Comics taking their
careers in their own hands and creating
their own opportunities and to see it
all
in action from them hearing the podcast
to putting it into reality and getting
to like see it it was just it was very
surreal it was very emotional and I was
very moved by the entire experience so I
just I just love what's happening here
at hot breadth and the comics that
really do listen and share it and put
the things into action it's just it just
makes my heart smile Yoshi so I really
want to start off on that positive note
to be honest yeah so fire fire
foreign oh that was what's goody I don't
know where the fi oh here it is fire
fire there you go
nah that's awesome man I mean I think at
the end of the day right it's like we've
been talking about this and this is kind
of like you mentioned like how hot
breath was born is that you just kind of
realize hey
no one's going to make your success for
you you got to go Gotta Go
go get it rather than waiting for people
to give stuff to you and I think that's
a that's a thing I know that you know as
we watch
some of the most successful comedians
coming up now
everybody's went and just went and got
it you know what I mean like no one's
waiting for somebody else to be like Oh
I'm gonna put you on I'm gonna put you
on
everyone just goes and kind of just gets
what they need kind of thing right and I
think that resonates with a lot of
people because we're starting to find
out I mean not that we're starting to
find out but
the game has changed you know what I
mean the comedy game has changed it's
not like The Gatekeepers are the ones
controlling absolutely everything uh you
know we talked last week about producing
shows to produce a show you just gotta
find a venue you don't have to wait for
a thing called a comedy club to put on a
show there's so many Brewery shows
there's so many restaurant shows there's
so many shows at different venues you
can put on a comedy show and those
things can make you money right and
those things can get you stage time and
those things can help you get better at
comedy so I love it when people just
take
the work ethic that they already have
and working on their jokes and getting
up at open mics
and are just like hey let's just find a
venue that will have us
um use the leverage that we have use the
connects that we have uh get people up
and then hopefully pay people as well so
I I just love the fact that even if
you're not paying people at least giving
those people opportunities but also
having a supportive Community as well
that says oh we'll support this so yeah
that's that's so legit that's like the
best part that's why I love producing
because I love watching people get
almost like get introduced to Comedy
time at the end of it like oh we got to
do that again that's why I like
producing in the suburbs man because
these people man need a laugh and then
you could tell that it's been a while
when they've had a laugh and you're like
oh oh yeah dude yeah that's what this
was it was a small town outside of
Atlanta that there just isn't comedy and
they were so hungry and thirsty for it
yeah yeah and that's just a fun feeling
so uh congrats that's Bobby congrats
Joyce that's just amazing and all the
people that were on the show that's
freaking awesome yeah amen there we go
and for people that don't know angels on
y'all our sound effect that we end the
live streams with is actually Bobby's
voice Angel's on y'all so um
good stuff so I just want to share that
positive start off this episode with
some positivity and hopefully maybe a
little a little inspiration this week
for people listening of like oh maybe
I'll go out there and get it or start
looking for my own venue we went to more
detail on all that last week of you know
with finding the right venue and things
like that but um
yeah it it can add up for sure
yeah yeah no that's awesome man and I
came straight from that to the World
Series of Comedy like World Series
comedy was here in Atlanta all week
basically and we we had the CEO Joe
lauers on
um we've had the like the vice president
Jason Roland on here before like we love
those guys and what they do with World
Series and um they were in Atlanta this
week I went two nights in a row and then
you actually competed in it yeah like
what yeah share your experience
with it because you've done it a few
times and
yeah better and better you know I
literally did it last week in Florida
and then did it again this week in um
in Atlanta
um I mean honestly like I guess the
biggest thing is
I know
the the World Series is one of those
things that you learn how to do a
showcase set and a showcase set is
really a set that is meant for Bookers
and meant for people to be like Oh I'm
going to book you based off what I am
watching so there's a level of I would
say technique to a showcase set that is
super important
um and showcase sets are really just
about
it's you get five minutes seven minutes
ten minutes whatever it may be but
you're highlighting pretty much the best
of it's like basically the compilation
of your best material right and within
that five minutes I you know I I don't
want to sound like it's as simple as
this but you got to try to get as many
laughs as possible within those five
minutes and the key is also to make sure
that you establish exactly who you are
and what you are so people know what
they're about to get up top it's almost
like a Jason who's the vice president
almost calls it like a defining
statement that sort of sets up the rest
of your set to then give you leeway to
say whatever you want within those five
minutes and it's not like you can't jump
from topic to topic it's just you have
to Define yourself like pretty much up
top or very very quickly within the
first couple of uh things that you say
so people know what they're about to get
with the rest of your set and they you
just try to you know I would say just
try to be as funny as possible
um
you know uh did it on Friday I want
sorry did it on Thursday night I won
that competition and then uh did the
semifinals on Saturday I did not win
that competition so they picked the top
three
um was that upset yeah I was upset but
also like I also realized maybe one
thing that I'm starting to like
probably adjust for
is that the folks who are uh
I guess this is the best way to describe
it it's not always about the funniest
it's about the most bookable
and I recognize that there's a
difference in that
and maybe it's just me but but I would
say that I've started to see sort of
like definitely a pattern of just like
even if like a room is hot and a
comedian just destroys
that may not necessarily mean that that
person is bookable for that club or not
because the club Owners are the ones who
are choosing as well so just remember
there's definitely a book ability and
then also like
is this the funniest person you've ever
heard because the club Owners are
choosing based on who they would want to
be back at the club the other thing to
remember is that the club Owners also
and the guys who are judging
also like
someone can book you off of watching
your set even if they don't move you on
there's been many of uh competitions
that I've been to that I've gotten
booked just off of my set I did move on
in the competition but I still got
booked which is still like a win-win
like at the end of the day that's kind
of what we are there for anyway like
this competition the reward is work
right the reward is like we're just
gonna you're gonna get a feature weekend
and hopefully you become in rotation
with the club and things like that I
know uh the guy who won the World Series
last year
uh got a feature weekend up in um
Sarasota
destroyed it and the club owner was just
like you're not featuring any longer
you're going to be headlining
from here on out so they put him in
rotation to headline just because he
just did so well right and that's what
we're all hoping for definitely from a
club Booker perspective
um so yeah that was kind of my
experience
um is that they're you know the club
Owners are allowed to book you even if
you don't win or even if you don't move
on in the competition I think the
competition is definitely just more
meant to be like okay this is who we
find to be the most bookable
um and I'd say my set has changed over
time my set changed from last week I
adjusted my set even from last week
based on notes based on sort of how I
wanted to adjust what I was saying
um I was happy with both sets
and definitely like good with it
um but you know I think it took me like
a day to be like all right it is what it
is kind of thing you know my feelings
were still hurt but I was like man I
still got bookings off of this and you
know the owner was just like oh good
good stuff I've never seen you better so
it's like that's a huge compliment
because she actually hasn't seen me in
some time so that's just always a good
thing and that Echoes you
talking about like focusing on what you
can control and creating opportunities
so like at a certain point at a festival
or competition you can only control what
you can control which is preparing and
having fun with the performance and then
whatever happens happens afterwards for
sure yeah yeah preparing
um yeah I think that's the big thing
preparing and having fun I would say are
the sort of the Milestones that I've
adopted in the last probably in the last
year with this competition I think I let
a lot of the competition get to my head
I can get a very heady sometimes and
very like into my set and try to dissect
it like for every single word and all
that and I recognized that I wasn't
having fun when I did that so this year
the focus was just
hey
I know that I get the biggest reaction
when I feel like I'm having a good time
so if I'm having a good time the
audience is going to have a good time
yeah and that's most important for me as
a performer I know myself that if I'm
having a good time on stage I am just a
hundred percent positive that the
audience is going to have a good time so
I tried not to Rob myself of that so I
make sure I go in we're going to have a
good time before we step on the stage
and that's the attitude that I go in
with
yeah and Bob Kirk asks did you do the
same set
for the two different performances you
did and how much time did you have to do
uh the first one so the first one in the
competition there's a Wild Card round
that is five minutes and for that Wild
Card round it's usually like 15 people I
was not in the wild card
um I was in the sort of the first round
in the first round is seven minutes so I
did a seven minute set
um and that seven minute set was
definitely
something uh that I did again for the 10
minute set so I basically did the same
seven
and added three more minutes to the
already seven minutes that I did from
the Thursday uh
I think I wish I would have done it a
little differently though I think I
think next time
um because the way I typically prepare
my Set uh just me personally I usually
know my first joke and my last joke and
this is just me that I don't want to
take away from anybody like this is just
my own sort of uh methodology I know the
first thing I'm gonna say like the first
joke and I know the last joke everything
kind of in between is just what I've got
in my bag of jokes and I just let it
kind of come based on how the audience
reacts the audience reacts to stuff like
just a little bit more I may go on that
certain topic and just do more jokes if
they don't then I may switch it up and
try a different topic but the majority
of the sets that I'm doing like in town
when I like do a features I mean when I
do a feature set or when I do even long
sets because I don't have an order I
just know the first thing and I know the
last thing and then everything else in
between is just straight up from the
bags from the back like I just I've got
the Arsenal it's just where where are we
gonna go like when we did the when we
did the um the uh the country club The
Country Club bit right
I just knew that I wanted to start in a
certain way and then when they reacted
to the HOA material I was like I'm gonna
give you more HOA material you know what
I'm saying and I just added more to it
you know I'm saying so that's kind of
how I organize my longer sets so I wish
I would have done that in this 10 minute
set because it it would have felt more
natural I definitely felt like I was
forcing
seven minutes plus add three more
minutes
which I actually have never done before
of just three minutes of a longer bit
that I actually have that's more like a
five minute that I then squeezed that's
kind of thing so that is probably the
only thing I wish I would have done
differently
yeah and that versatility and being able
to Pivot and stuff comes with Stage time
and having enough material that you can
kind of plug and play but all that all
that develops incrementally over time
for any Comics listening we're like oh
how do you do that it's literally like
you just get more and more comfortable
on stage you get less and less in your
head and you're more able to actually
listen to the audience and you start to
have that dialogue instead of this
monologue you have with an audience for
several years in the stand up if you
just I gotta say these jokes as I wrote
them as as I prepared them and you just
do it you know this those are all part
of learning and developing as a comedian
until you get to the point where you can
be a little more like flexible on stage
but it comes with time sure yeah I would
say like one of the biggest comedians
who I saw do this I saw him do it at the
punch line and then I saw him do it when
I put him when I had him on a show up in
um in downtown Duluth Georgia was uh
Drew Thomas uh killer Drew Thomas spent
the first five minutes of his set just
like talking with the crowd just like
asking how they were doing asking who's
married who's not married and then you
could just like see the wheels turning
and what he did was legit just do a set
based on all the talk of the first five
minutes so he hit all the people in the
crowd and then the next show they talked
about something completely different and
he readjusted now I heard some some of
the same stuff but then he readjusted
his set for that crowd it was just like
magical to watch I was like oh that's
kind of cool he's not just doing the
same stuff he's legit just like it was
almost like bobbing and weaving based on
the audience and what the audience told
him was like what they it's not like
what they wanted to hear but he's just
like like he had like someone he asked
somebody uh
what their job was like if you know and
they said lawyer or something he had a
lawyer joke that he prompted into the
bid for the next 45 minutes like it was
just all these little things that I
thought was just super awesome to watch
and this was like years ago because I
think to your point I was also very much
like I got it 10 minutes you don't get
these 10 minutes it's gonna get Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam and then
um when I realized I had like enough
material I I was like oh I don't have to
I have enough stuff that covers a wide
variety of
topics I'll be okay and that's worked
for me for a very long time
yeah and speaking of uh lawyer jokes
Abby
Penn
Pam Nani uh his roast is about someone
who would mispronounce his name which is
hilarious but basically he said
Joel you look like your dad is a lawyer
and you're the one giving him legal
troubles
but Dad
I wanted to take the car that's
hilarious
yeah that's very funny
that is very very funny yes I come from
a long line of trade school graduates so
a lot of money in the body in the
buyer's household
if anyone wants to get on that
maintenance at a juvenile center money
Holla At Your Boy
I know the head of Maintenance at a
local juvie Center that I can probably
get you some nepotism in on
um hilarious
all right so let's get into your
questions now that we're all caught up
there and uh yeah Drew Thomas is a beast
he's been on the podcast twice if you
guys want to go back and listen to those
episodes the second episode I did with
him was actually after a road gig we did
together we recorded it in a waffle
house and it's just raw comic talk man
so um yeah I remember you telling me
like which is also another thing I
picked up from Drew about like watching
people and then watching yourself and
recognizing that the laughs were
different like yeah I was featuring for
him that was the night we recorded the
podcast after I was featuring for him
and I was like I feel good about that
set and then he went up like his
laughter was just different and I was
just like
I was like bro
as soon as you're feeling good you're
like oh that's another level yeah yeah
yeah by the way you had a great set on
uh was it Friday that you did it
oh the World Series yeah oh thank you
man I enjoyed that yeah I had a lot of
fun with it yeah
the sugar bit was hilarious
oh I'm more yeah I'm trying to work out
some new stuff you know yeah
so it was yeah yeah that was a lot of
fun it was a hot crowd so I just I just
rode the wave you know oh yeah yeah oh
my God Steve says Joe looks like a youth
pastor that would try to do hip-hop
songs by acoustic guitar
laughs
[Laughter]
oh my gosh this q a is just a roast
y'all that's amazing
I'll take it I'll take it from the
windows to the walls
yeah
oh amen amen amen oh amen amen that
reminds me of Jeff cohn's joke he had
about being like the the Christian
Metallica cover band it's hilarious
that's a good joke he crushed you yeah
he killed it was great yeah
um
so yeah let's get into y'all's questions
here on the live stream
and uh we're sitting at a solid 25
people right now uh the live stream is
back baby back thank you all for hanging
out live or listening to this later we
really want to be more intentional about
building up this weekly live stream to
become a community event where Comics
can ask questions and also meet and
interact with each other as well that's
that's a big part of the hot breath
versus Comics just connecting with other
comics
so um
thank you all for for being a part of
this as we're as we're continuing to
build this higher and higher as fire
fire
so the first question I'm seeing here is
from Amir
it says
um if you're a comic who has dark
material that gets groans
how do you set the tone how do you make
people feel comfortable to laugh
that's a good question I always say
there's nothing wrong with like dark
material but just know that groaning
isn't the appropriate response that you
want from an audience
so I think when it comes to a groan I
think what I see a lot of times is that
people set up those jokes
to be grown worthy by saying like some
ridiculous word or by saying some
trigger word and they get the groan
versus sort of rephrasing the setup
and I think rephrasing the setup to
where you bring people into why you feel
like this is a topic so I mean I'm I'm
gonna let's say you're talking about
horror films right if you wanted to talk
about horror films you don't say you
guys seen the latest horror films that
where people everybody is dying
like that's just a groan right versus
uh I don't like horror films where
everybody's dying I think they're a
little ridiculous now you can go into
whatever your setup your joke is around
why you feel it because now it's more
about you versus just the lonely part of
just saying oh y'all seen that horror
film where everybody's killing each
other then people are like what what are
you talking about kind of thing so I
think there's a rephrasing of a setup
where it becomes more about your take on
it rather than just the material part
and I think Young Comics get into this
uh
what's the word trap of just trying to
say a trigger word or trying to say
something just because they think
they're trying to get a reaction from
people
and it's not worthy like a groan isn't
what you want as a response like we're
doing comedy like I don't know what kind
of entertainment you want to do where
you get gross you know what I'm saying
like yeah but personalizing it like you
said and kind of easing into it a little
bit before you just drop the hammer is a
great way yeah yeah
yeah I love that advice yeah I have
nothing really to add to that and uh I
will say sometimes young Comics look at
someone like Bill Burr Anthony jeselnick
and they're like oh I want to do that
and they haven't learned how to write a
joke yet so then they get a grown and
they're like oh PC culture everybody's
woke and won't laugh at these half-baked
ideas I wrote on a napkin in between my
shifts washing dishes like
some like some young Comics like try to
go for these topics before they
understand how to make their dog funny
or how to make just their everyday like
brushing their teeth funny it's kind of
like for a kind of crawl before you walk
especially when you're getting to the
dark material
yeah like if you can't make a joke about
traffic funny don't try a joke about
abortion you mean like it's just way too
like those comedians are able to make
those jokes and able to sort of do that
pivot because they've had practice like
they've literally practiced decades
years and Decades of just like
practicing with materials so their
ability to finesse like the English
language is just so much further than
where you are so I think it's helpful
just to know that like
it's not needed to try to get the grown
a grown just is not a desired reaction
yep
so it's a yeah it's a marathon so you
know crawl before you walk here but
great I mean yeah great advice on that
one you know she's just personalizing it
give a little more context for the dark
material Beyond just a stranger on stage
trying to say this crazy thing
personalizing I think really makes it
more digestible
yeah nice
yeah yeah that is fire fire
all right bow bow
oh and Logan said it's been wonderful to
be a part of the hot breath Community
thank you Logan appreciate it boss and
uh he said I'm producing a show mid-june
Bobby Sutton gave me some wonderful
advice about having a backup
and the mentality of a producer is there
any other advice you could give
well we've kind of we've talked a lot
about producing your own show last week
um something I don't think we mentioned
last week
is booking the show based on quality and
not who or your friends or not
like a lot of times the producer is like
I'm friends with this person or that
person let me just put all my friends on
here regardless of how funny they are
but your lineup like it matters and the
Order of your show matters yeah big time
matters it matters what matters most is
that the audience there has a good time
and wants to come back and tell their
friends and that is based on the quality
of your lineup so that's something I
would say for producing
is produce for quality and not
necessarily all your friends
yeah very very true I think I mean I
know some people don't want to hear it
but like
I was at a show recently where like
a heavy hitter went third and did not
headline
and it was very hard for the person
afterwards to get laughs because just
somebody just legit just destroyed it
just like
it
and I think that's a that's a hard thing
for some people to hear
but not all comedians are built the same
so you have to know
that like
just like you put your best or second
best joke up top you put your second
best comedian on top and your best
comedian as your closer like if you're
doing a lineup I think it's super
important and in the middle you kind of
can go sort of different orders but you
just try to if anything you want a
crescendo of like start strong and then
get stronger stronger stronger the best
kind of thing yep when possible
um and then I think different styles
um diversity on shows I think is super
important uh to have a different tone to
your to your show
um but yeah I think it's always
important to know your closure is so
important in a comedy show because
that's who you're uh producers are gonna
remember like oh yeah you're closer man
that was that was great if you hear your
closer was not great they remember that
more than everything else in the show
that's all they'll remember because
that's how they're leaving the show
feeling that's what they're gonna
remember is how they left the show
feeling yeah yeah so yeah that's a good
point I think the lineup is very very
important
Kaboom good good question Logan and
thank you Bobby for sharing some advice
uh to the hot breath of verse I love
hearing Comics helping Comics out there
uh the next
speaking of comics helping Comics all
the way from Sydney
Australia
oh my heavenly day we are all the way I
actually get a lot of um
I got quite a few messages from
Australia I was just on an Australian
comedian's podcast as well like
I love uh hot breadth versus out there
in Australia oh wait is that you
no oh what just happened there we go
excuse me everyone sorry I don't know
what just happened there
um all right and uh his name Sheehan or
shahan what are these names
shahan
igas you see how quickly I went through
the last name I was like I don't want to
end on that g
um we'll just do Sheehan or shahan hi
Joel and Yoshi I'm from Sydney Australia
and moving to America by January next
year
as I got lucky on the Green Card Lottery
and want to know what are the good
comedy cities in the country where you
can get up every night without having to
move to the craziness of a city like New
York LA or Chicago
[Laughter]
um I mean we're probably biased I'm
probably biased on this but I think
Atlanta is a great comedy City
um but if the if I was to say where I
think I have heard from other comedians
who come to town and where I've been in
other places across the country I'd say
Atlanta Austin Denver
are like the top sort of bigger cities
Seattle is pretty sight pretty tight on
as a comedy scene in terms of what I've
heard other comedians say they'd get up
a lot
um
because you just gotta think size of the
city if it's a comedy City and it's got
you know not to belabor the details but
if it's got a lot of if it's got
millions of people
you're going to get a lot of
opportunities to go up Houston is also a
pretty good city in terms of just lots
of opportunities just because the bigger
cities have way more opportunity they
might have more clubs for people to
actually go to
and things like that so those I would
say the top for me is probably Austin
Atlanta Denver in terms of like
mid-tier cities below New York La I
would also call I would actually say the
top two were New York and LA but Chicago
I would also I actually put Chicago and
Atlanta in the same kind of breath
yeah yeah that's you look at all the
high notes there but Atlanta yeah yeah
I'm biased too coming up in Atlanta but
Atlanta has shows every single night and
people are like killing it and people
are like
killing it and helping each other
there's like a good Community here in
Atlanta like I see Comics like being
very supportive of each other here which
is very encouraging because it was like
not that way when I came up in the team
you know so
uh yeah I'm biased but Atlanta's you
named a lot of good cities but yeah for
me Atlanta Atlantis that's the reason I
didn't move because Atlanta had
everything I needed here to just develop
and get good at comedy so
[Music]
uh that's a good comprehensive list
there though
yeah yeah I mean and I would say Austin
is getting bigger uh mostly because a
lot of comics moved from LA to Austin I
hear Miami and Fort Lauderdale is
actually pretty good scenes in terms of
like they're coming up and there's a lot
of comedians that have also moved to
Florida as well so yeah I think there's
definitely
plenty of cities for you to where you
can get up on a nightly basis but just
know like a city even like Atlanta
though you can get up every night
uh you gotta have material
like because the competitions that's
what I'm saying go into competitive
scene will keep you inspired to keep
creating because you're like oh man I
gotta keep up here yes yeah
you can't be slacking that's the best
way to say it like you can't slack off
because people like not that people will
know but like you're gonna realize that
oh why am I not getting on well your
material hasn't changed or it's not
keeping up with people who are getting
booked and getting showcased yep
uh Phil Kettering he actually posted
this
in our Facebook group I promoted this in
our Facebook group
and he actually commented on here with a
question I meant to get to first because
I said people who comment on here will
get first dibs
and then it ends up being fifth dibs so
it's all good Phil I appreciate Phil I'm
doing a show with Phil
and uh Bristol
in May May
19th and 20th I'll be at the Blue Ridge
Comedy Club up there with Phil doing a
clean comedy weekend no
um talk about Comics helping Comics you
know Phil reached out I was like would
you be interested in headlining this
Comedy Club
uh yes
so anyone looking to book Joel or Yoshi
the people you're listening to were
qualified and able and our wives
appreciate you
they sure do they might even send you
flowers yes yes
from the garden yes
the garden looking good we got some
roses coming up dude you gotta see these
floribundas blooming out here bro
but that's
are Claire Austins are looking good very
fragrant for those of you in the live
stream here's a few
there's a few for you right there look
at you boy
so fragrant
oh my gosh they're so good
all right so anyway
um
Phil's question was there are a lot of
different joke writing books available
what are your top three that have helped
you the most
oh
I'm gonna turn around just to see if I
can
see some of the books
I will
I will preface this by saying I've only
read one cover to cover
now with this question
people should know
we did a whole comedy author Series
where we literally interviewed
all the top comedy authors basically if
you go on Amazon and you search comedy
writing books all the top authors we
interviewed we put together like in
order a comedy author series and then
had like a recap episode talking about
all the big takeaways from all these
different comedy authors so if you
thought hot breath was the best comedy
resource it just got even better with
that context for y'all to know because
nobody's doing that
um but for sure
the one I've read cover to cover
yeah and the one that I started with
is and this is like joke writing books
not like Steve Martin's biography or
anything like that but the one I read
cover to cover and that taught me
one-liners is Greg Dean's step by step
to stand up that's okay it's the book I
started with if you're looking to learn
one-liners and you don't want to take
our five steps to funny workshop for
whatever reason
um that's available Linked In the show
notes then that's a good book that'll
help you do that
um yeah so one-liners yeah that's solid
uh the I've read
all the comedy books that I've probably
read maybe like five or six but I would
say the top one for me in terms of like
started out with and if went back to the
revised version of this book Judy
Carter's comedy Bible freaking godsend
of a book it is so well structured uh
just the prompts are amazing in it
um I'm also going to give a shout out to
uh somebody else you've had on the
podcast
um Jerry corley's uh sort of like
architecture book on the 13 archetypes
of a joke uh he's got this entire
um breakdown of jokes it's in a PDF
format I don't think it's in a book
format that is like a hundred and
something Pages freaking amazing
resource so those are breaking comedy
DNA one
yeah yeah that is legit one of the best
straight up like practical uh joke
writing technique books that I've ever
ever read I've one of my best jokes came
out of using those exercises that still
kills till today
um so yeah those are those probably the
be like if I was to say three yeah I I
also agree with Greg Danes like I've
read that one too soup just just good
like it's just a good on one-liners here
to your point but it's like the setup of
the of just getting to the highlights of
jokes and things like that that book is
awesome
yeah that's a solid top three so uh Greg
Dean's step by step to stand up in no
particular order I think this is how we
brought them up but Greg Dean step by
step to stand up
you said Judy Carter's the comedy Bible
and Jared corley's breaking comedy's DNA
I think that's a solid that's a solid
top three there yeah sure yeah and
there's oh there's there's plenty of
others I would you know uh go out and
check them out but I think you know if I
was to say there's those three I can
always kind of like go back to try
different exercises like I go back to
Greg Dean's exercises as well and Judy
Carter's when I'm writing like new
topics and the way that they do their uh
prompts writing prompts both of them
have writing prompts that are just
really really good if you're exploring
like a brand new topic as well which I
think is awesome
and speaking of writing prompts goodness
every day on our Facebook group
OG Bobby Sutton posts a new word every
single day it's the right Ten Club
10 a.m eastern time every single day
Bobby's posted a new word for you to
just write a joke about post it in there
get feedback from other people read
other people's jokes share some feedback
it's a great it's kind of like it's like
Wordle for comedians where it's kind of
like a puzzle you have to solve and I
think that's all I saw someone asking
the uh the live chat about like how
I think that was Abby asking just like
oh specific on the right tank Club some
words are harder than others
do you have any advice on dealing with
like
like just finding jokes basically and
like comedy writing is it's a law of
averages it's literally like you write
10 jokes you write 20 jokes and you may
end up keeping one of them like that's
literally the joke running process so
most of what you write You're Not Gonna
Keep yeah if you guys think about the
way that late nights stand up and like
lay light late night monologues work
they've got like 10 writers in the room
all 10 of those writers are literally
writing close to like 200 jokes and they
only say like maybe 30 maybe 40 jokes by
the time it's over but they've literally
seen thousands of jokes so yeah it's a
law of averages I would honestly say the
hot breath daily writing exercise it's
probably the best exercise I've done in
terms of just keeping sharp from a
writing perspective yeah like it's just
good like I'll just go in one day and
just like oh what's the word and just
write because it kind of frees you and
sort of helps you get away from feeling
stuck because now you just write about
this certain thing
um so you're not stuck on your own
material which I think is so helpful
sometimes because sometimes you can just
be like in a funk be like I don't feel
like anything is funny well write about
a bat
just do that
today's word was like intense you know
it's just a word it's just a jumping off
point just something to get the juices
flowing
yeah
look great yeah and Bob Bobby got on to
me at the show she's like right 10 Club
come on Joel you know where where you at
fam wait yeah
live stream I think I had a little PTSD
from during the pandemic I did a live
stream right 10 club for over 400 days
in a row third day
and then she was sure to clarify you
don't have to go live you don't have to
go live but just people would appreciate
maybe you participating in this thing
you created to help Comics you know so
um so since then I've I've been doing it
I've been back in there doing it and
reading other people's jokes as well and
posting my own so it is it is a great
way to start the day and just to say oh
I wrote today it's a 10 minute exercise
so we can be like oh look I wrote today
yeah hilarious
um
oh this is great yeah great questions
there
and um
let's let me see
un momento
let's do a few more here as we're gonna
land the plane here but this will be
saved as a podcast for sure and then
that was a question in our Facebook
group
um
yes this will be our podcast is whale
uh next question
coming from mudit
what's a good way to write new crowd
work bits would writing out possible
crowd work responses and follow-up jokes
be a good start oh I hear Ian
oh I hear Ian bag
just yelling at his computer right now
if you guys don't know Ian bag he's
known as probably the best crowd work
comedian in the world I mean
you've heard everyone from Tom Segura
and Bert Kreischer to Joe Rogan talk
about this guy and just how amazing he
is and he's known as like the best crowd
work comic we've had him on the show
and one of the things he got annoyed
with the most was about these young
Comics just using crowd work as a way to
set up material and stuff
um which was hilarious to hear as the
new trend is not even to do material but
just do crowd work to get the clip to go
viral to sell out the venue to not have
the material to bomb to never get booked
again you know that whole cycle
um what's a good way to write new crowd
work bits
I mean right I I mean I'm gonna sound
like an old head here but yeah I don't
say right crowd work bits I mean
they do the all right all right
so here's the thing I think just like
just like Ian bagg has said and has
practice right like I think there was a
time when Ian said he's just like
the way he worked on crowd work was just
to do crowd work and he just got really
good at doing crowd work based off of
that but he's got material right he's
got material that he's written and
things of that nature and there's
nothing really wrong with like practice
but crowd work is meant to be like kind
of organic and doing that stuff so yeah
I mean even if you practice those things
and practice you know a response to
somebody
when it comes to crowd work you never
know what people are going to say so yes
you can have something canned but people
can also tell if it feels canned as well
so just be prepared for that as well
um and I think when it does come to
crowd work just know that like yes crowd
work is working and it's clippy and it
helps you you know the algorithms love
crowd work that's that we know like the
all the reels and all the Facebooks and
all they all love crowd work but I think
what it is is that that's where people
feel uh it's because it's getting the
most response from an audience and from
people perspective people are sticking
with crowd work because they're waiting
for what is going to happen from a
crowdwork perspective versus just a joke
that you're telling
and which is why it's much more viral so
I would say if you're going to do crowd
work yeah go ahead and practice it
but just know like at the end of the day
people don't come see an entire show
full of crowd work
I mean I don't know anyone is do you
know any comedians who are just doing
just purely crowd work as an entire show
I mean Ian bagg is
Todd Berry did a special of just people
doing crowd work specials and things
like that but it's usually weaved in
yeah you gotta have material I mean I
don't want to sugarcoat it you got to
have material you gotta have jokes like
yeah I would focus on developing
material more than developing crowd work
yes I was I mean that's for longevity
um now that could be me being an old
head who's like these kids in their
crowd work Clips I don't know the
mentality now I can't imagine starting
now and being like Oh my gosh I have to
learn how to write a joke and I have to
learn how to film and edit and add
captions and make sure I get that Viral
moment at this open mic in front of
seven people like
so it's and that's including the staff
including and the homeless guy staff
peeing in the corner
um
but anyway I literally I used to show on
a patio and there was a homeless guy he
didn't pee but he did just like stand in
the corner and it was very weird
um
but anyway uh
yeah so I would focus for a long term
developing your material instead of your
crowd work
but a common thing people will do is do
crowd work that weaves into their
material like oh how long have you all
been married and then oh I have all
these marriage jokes type deal oh or
you're on a dating app I have these
dating app jokes but I would say focus
on the material
um focus on the material but I see
Winston Hodges in the live chat who is
uh if you want to see crowd work done
right he's killing it and he does a lot
of great crowd work on his social media
uh so he's a good comic who's doing it
actually like the right quality way if
you guys want a good example there he's
killing it
yeah uh
uh next up I just love seeing the Hop
red rivers here yo this is so dope oh my
gosh
um
let me do a few more let me know
let me see let me see
um here's a good one in our Facebook
group uh from Terry Terry
Terry says how do you write comedy punch
lines how do you brainstorm ideas for
comedy punch lines do you draw from life
experiences or watch the news
oh my gosh and Jeff Arnold just said
Joel with his rom-com
okay
yeah I mean it looks like a haircut two
hours you look like you've got to be
broken up with
I'm Legit had this haircut two hours
I was so jazzed to come on the live
stream be like yo look at the drip look
at the swagatude
I got my Goodwill Tommy Bahama shirt on
and then people are just like bro
chill bro
all right uh but yeah Terry basically
asking how do you come up with ideas for
jokes and um
write jokes basically well there's a
whole online class we have about this
and a workshop as well if you want
something a little quicker and shorter
but um episodes and every week Tuesday
live feedback uh but yeah yeah sure but
the short and sweet answer for me I
would say is just yeah draw from Life
Experiences what do you find funny
brainstorm ideas don't don't brainstorm
for the punch line in mind brainstorm
for what's interesting to you what what
excites you what's something unique
about you what is something that you
could talk about that no one else could
talk about Yoshi and I are both married
we can both do marriage material but
what makes it unique to us is our own
experience our own unique point of view
so I would say brainstorm around those
areas and look for the surprising
elements of those things because a lot
of Comedy hinges on surprise so start to
look in those areas and
do what you think is funny write it out
take it to the stage see how it goes
uh yeah like step number one I would
just take like a small little notebook
and start making notes of what you find
funny so you can start to make uh like a
mental note of your humor in what things
sort of make you crack up so uh I
started doing that before I started
comedy probably for like six months of
kind of just where my humor was
um to then sort of figure out how to
write for that type of humor obviously
you know for any comedian like surprise
is the ultimate element of a setup
somebody's making an assumption based on
that setup and then you surprise them
with uh something different that's how
you elicit the laughter but really it's
just all about practicing that on an
ongoing basis write it practice it
everything sounds good on paper
but you got to get it on that stage the
stage is the final frontier because
that's what Cinema quarks asked too is
how do you know if something's funny
before staying on stage and it's
literally like you don't until you get
up there like you just do what you think
is gonna work and then the audience will
let you know
yes yes the audience is the ultimate uh
yeah they're the ultimate sort of
vindicators of whether you should have
done that or not
yep but that's how you'll know is
getting on stage getting over that hump
uh oh and Cinema Quirk said they just
subbed today and they don't know who
Yoshi is
who are you Yoshi who am I man don't I
I'd say this I am just a comedian just
trying to adjust things happen I am a
comedian just trying to make things
happen no I've been doing comedy for
about eight years now uh I actually
started taking Joe's class that's
actually how we met
um I've been producing shows for like
six years now I'm an improviser I'm a
writer I'm an executive producer I've
done a movie uh I I do a lot man and uh
I enjoy this comedy game and I'm like
full force I do a lot of comedy in the
suburbs I'm a clean comedian I'm a
corporate comedian you know what I'm
saying I'll send you a resume if you
need you know what I'm saying but yeah
yeah I'm out here in these comedy
streets baby
big facts yeah and I guess you and I'll
go on the road together a lot or do like
local like country club gigs and stuff
Yoshi's the my right hand man which yeah
um Steve Polgar asked how do I utilize
the hot breadth Network to book
comedians well just you know you start
with us
uh you know if you want to book meetings
from the hopper at the verse you're like
oh Joel and Yoshi
could be a good show or one or the other
could be a good show
um if you want to bring the bag but if
you're looking for
um we can negotiate we can talk about
price and all that sure I mean here's
the thing the hot breath network is all
over the country is all over the world
uh leverage it to kind of uh come up in
to see where people are and I'm sure
there's people going to be close to your
city
um I performed in other cities where a
hot breath averse folks were and it was
amazing they helped me get up when
people come to this city I help them get
up uh you know it's it's all love man
which is my favorite thing is to just
help people get better at comedy
yeah so uh yeah even just posting in our
Facebook group and Steve is in our hot
breath Pro Group which is where people
who sign up for our online writing class
go there and they do a live Writing Room
in there every day that Joan runs or not
every day every day Monday every Monday
Jones riding room and anytime there's
gigs that come up uh hot breath that's
that's the group I post in first so uh
yeah if you're looking to book people
Steve the pro group would be a good
place to start
and uh you just you just never know
who's in the hot breath first
there's people of all levels in here
so yeah he's planning charity events and
Steve said he's playing charity events
and
uh Seattle San Fran Denver New York and
Long Island yeah yeah yeah yeah
very nice
I love it go yeah good stuff there Steve
I love seeing that people do it just
love me I know how to get people's money
[Laughter]
gotcha
I think uh I think we got to most of
these here's we've kind of come to the
the end of the hour here
oh man but we um we appreciate everyone
for
hanging out we do this every single
Tuesday on our YouTube channel
I'm sorry I saw Aaron ask
when people pay for shows should Comics
use notes I would say no on a paid show
on a page show absolutely not that we
can agree on yes okay
okay we differ on if they should have
notes on stage in general but with Open
Mic or from like open mic right yeah but
if it's like a paid paid show no notes
no notes yeah yeah
cool like you gotta be I I just feel you
just have to look as professional as
possible and
if you look like you're like notes just
makes it looks like you're working
something out which is why I'm okay with
it on a Open Mic because you're working
out the joke but if someone's paying you
to be like up there unless that's like
your stick and you're like a Deon Cole
or something
then no
yeah yeah you got to come off the Dome
you got to know your material you got to
perform your time
yeah and the vibe asked how do I turn
conversational funny to the comedy turn
conversational funny to the comedy stage
yeah I mean the short answer is you get
on stage
that's how comfortable you get on there
the more confident you will be and the
more conversational it will be
so a lot of that conversational just
comes from stage presence and Stage
confidence that you can really only
develop on stage
yeah yeah you just gotta try it I mean I
think your the majority of people's
first time doing comedy is usually from
someone saying that they're really funny
and they should try it or somebody
losing like a fantasy football league or
something right yeah
so and most people are going to go with
I've got this funny story right but the
reality is a funny story may not have a
set up a punchline it's just a funny
story and it's great for a dinner party
but comedy has you know jokes have a
structure and jokes have sort of a way
that you tell them so people so you
elicit a laughter which is what you want
whereas telling a story may be a little
different so it's about practice so
practice telling that story
it's probably gonna bomb try to get in a
different way shorten it up change it up
it's probably going to do better and
every time you tell that story it will
just get better and better and better
um use the writing prompts use the book
use a class you've got a class we've got
ways to help you write better
um yeah use the resources around you to
get better at writing
for show yeah and we'll put some links
in the the show description to those
books for y'all to check out
um it may or may not be Amazon affiliate
links so if you do get one of the books
your boy gets 20 cents so it really adds
up
fire fire
[Laughter]
well I've heard that in the other room
and goes fired fired fired
um
um and real quick Larry Harrell asking
about the best way to start a show
when there isn't something going on in
your area
uh wait
dang it I should have got out of here
I'm sorry I see these questions and I
want to help but we should get out of
here but basically trying to get
something going but what would be the
best way to start a show or put together
a show about without feeling obligated
to be the host or MC
um oh that's a hard one so I would say
uh without feeling if you can find
somebody that can actually do that for
you then go ahead and do that but just
know that just because you don't have
like a
um
like a place that does comedy any
restaurant that does any kind of
entertainment is likely going to also be
open to Comedy as long as you can find a
way to sell them that bring in comedy
either keeps people there bringing
comedy sort of builds a community
there's very many ways to sell white
comedy would be good like you know how
many acoustic
open mics can you have in one place
versus doing a comedy show for the same
amount of time kind of thing so that's
how I would sell it in a city that may
not have like a lot of options unless
you're talking about
like a city that has like one General
Store if you got to do comedy at the
general store then baby just go do
comedy at the General Store yeah yeah
yeah where yeah wherever you can create
it and we talked more detail about yeah
finding venues already doing like
karaoke or already doing trivia a
restaurant or whatever that's already
doing some sort of live event that could
you could kind of be like oh this would
fit into your like weekly like event
lineup type deal and uh Michelle asked
or Michael
so there's a good idea to organize an
open mic where comedians musicians can
participate
and how should the lineup look I mean
I've done those where they kind of do
music comedian music comedian I've done
poetry open mics I mean I've done I've
done karaoke before I was like do you
mind if I do jokes instead of uh singing
and they were cool with it so
um yeah I don't think there's anything
wrong with that yeah yeah
and it's open mic so you could alternate
or you know or do two comics and then
two musicians like I don't think there's
any wrong there
yeah I don't think so either yeah just
try it out see what happens
kaboom
all right
well let's uh let's land This Plane here
man we appreciate y'all for hanging out
with us
on this beautiful Tuesday yes we do this
every Tuesday 5 p.m Eastern Time
so we will be back
next Tuesday next Tuesday for another
live stream q a
but until then join our Facebook group
where we do those daily writing prompts
until then
have a good day hopper at the verse we
love you
[Music]